before you read the script did you know
about the book uh were you familiar with
it or is it something that you dove
right into as soon as you
you know got the script right in your
hands yeah i never fully read it i read
parts of it
um sort of as comparison pieces and
references with things like 1984 and
handmaid's tale
and all that all that spicy stuff
but this was the first time i kind of
sat and read it but to to be fair
once i sort of read it i put it aside
everything was in those scripts and in
fact
nina for me playing la nina
there's so much depth to her in the
scripts
that's um that kind of gets lost in in
the book
um she kind of ends up taking such a
backseat
um sign of the times and it's
amazing to be able to to kind of move
forward and just trust your script and
your showrunner what is it about this
character that
you find that there's such a curiosity
in her to see what else is out there
aside from the society that she's living
in
i think
i feel that as long as she can remember
there's been something in her that she
can't identify
when we feel disconnected
or sort of away from ourselves we have
words for it we're starting to
talk about it in this world there are no
words for it because no one feels that
way
the idea of sitting in that space for us
for so long
and then finally making a connection
with someone who
might maybe tell you that they might
maybe be feeling in a similar way
it's sort of mind-blowing and and
stepping into that as an actor it's
really cool yeah i bet um what is it
about the story that you love
or that you find fascinating or even
scary because this is
quite the dystopian society that's built
up
i really i really enjoyed um
sort of having to sit on
maybe sort of natural instincts and then
slowly
slowly letting them out and sort of
choosing
the the times in which to do that there
are
there were so many moments where i as me
would
feel shame or be excited or would just
fall in love and
uh whereas for nina it's it's a it's a
slower more complex
more private um experience and i feel
that one of my favorite things to be
able to do is to be able to
that i got to do in this was sit
quietly in a space and for that to be
the thing that's filmed and for it to be
very internal
um yeah
no that's great um i love sci-fi the
genre in general
what is it about this show that you
think will appeal to everyone
i think there is i think the comparison
with
the savage lands and new london the idea
that everyone sort of in new london is
kind of fascinated by the savage lands
but so
from but they're fascinated because they
know they can come back
yeah and the idea that everyone in the
savage lands
has no choice and can never participate
in this other part of the world
i think there is something in that we're
very
people want to explore we want to
question and people want to feel
connection and love and the fact that so
many of those things are just
unheard of or completely banned um
there's so much secrecy within what's
outside of those two worlds
what else is there how did it become
what it became yeah i think there's
there's a lot to
be found as the series um how would you
describe
the connection or just the the
relationship between
your character and harry lloyd's
character
i'd say that there's something so
lenina has had to interact with
bernard a lot he balances people's soma
levels and their levels out um and i
think
she's probably been a problem client for
a while
um and i think there's something about
his
conformity that really frustrates her
in that way that kind of your best
friends
do sometimes because you know
if you really know someone and i feel
like nina knows bernard
even without even before that kind of
connection that they have yeah
because she knows that when he says
everything's fine i'm great i always
feel
great i'm an alpha plus she can see that
that's not true yeah so not only is he
lying
but he might feel the same way that she
does
um so i think there's a sort of slow
exploration to that
um but they're very very different
people even though they might have
similar feelings of similar thing
okay so this might be a tricky question
i've had a variety of different answers
but if
if all of a sudden our society became
brave new world
um what would you choose the the
happiness
or would you choose the freedom freedom
definitely
yeah okay that's the easiest
answer then amazing um can we talk about
downton abbey for two seconds
yeah cool um what is it like being part
of a show
that even when it's wrapped up there's
just so much
fan base surrounding it it's incredible
you know you you do so many things
it's it really i think
the longer i've been acting the more i
realize now as i'm getting older
how rare it is that something is that
loved
and it's not just that people are
obsessed with it i think people really
really love it um and feel sort of a
deep connection
with it was you know over 10 years ago
that we started that job and i was so
young
um and new to acting you do realize how
rare that those experiences happen
i just think it's great when people love
a show
awesome also nice chatting with you
congrats on the show